he knows I don't have a treat so he's
not gonna listen come on kiss what
Maddie then everybody's watching and
this is super embarrassing we pop that's
not you're not doing it today we're in
my gym yes I know it's probably shocking
to a lot of you the fact that I have a
gym that I actually do anything fitness
related and in 2019 I definitely want to
get more into fitness content but don't
worry I'm not gonna be going away from
tech I want to mix Fitness and tech
because it has been something that I'm
so passionate and so interested in and
this past year you may see behind me
this is the peloton treadmill and I saw
this at SIA and shortly after it was
announced they had pre-orders so I just
got this maybe like a month ago the
pre-orders finally shift and I've been
wanting to make a video about it but
anyway we're here it's here and I want
to show it to you guys
and this gym is still a work in progress
so just there'll be another video on
that later you may be familiar with a
peloton the bikes and I am NOT a huge
fan of riding bikes at all but when I
saw they had the treadmill I was like
this is my time to shine because one of
the things that I did love about peloton
is they have live classes so what the
bike version you could take live classes
and you could also do things not on the
bike you can do floor exercises they
have like various boot camps so that
same thing applies to the treadmill so
here's some live classes you can click
count me in if you plan on being at that
class one of the best things that I like
about this is you don't actually have to
be here present for the live classes
they have a whole list of video
on-demand things
these classes that are live there then
archived and you take them later I will
say that the interface is not the best
and it kind of drives me insane
especially as a designer and coming from
like doing interfaces and things like
that I'm like why would you do this but
all that aside the treadmill is
incredible this screen is huge
some of the prototypes that I saw were
very small versions of this but this is
like an iMac that is on a freaking
treadmill like this is just absurd so
here's my calendar this is the last one
that I did this was on the let's see
okay I did the 20-minute Rock Fun Run
this was actually a digital one I was
traveling and they also have an iPhone
app so I did this run digitally so here
this was a 45 minute intermediate boot
camp that was my leaderboard rank two it
gives you your distance your elevation
the calories that you burn this is the
heartrate the one thing that I will say
they only have a one-size-fits-all heart
rate monitor so this one doesn't
actually fit me very well so that was
kind of struggling to actually get it to
connect unless it is tight across your
chest it doesn't give you an entirely
accurate read of your heart rate so I
was having some trouble with this but
for the most part when it does connect
it does seem to be pretty accurate what
I love about that is it will help you
get more accurate calorie readings so
what's cool is this was like half class
on the treadmill and then the other half
was on the floor so you kind of did
weighted things got an achievement man I
love achievements this is my personal
best it's not going to use a little walk
around this thing here so there's the
incline okay well now I'm going up is it
going up I feel like it's going up it's
going up it went up so here's your speed
knob I move it forward that goes faster
so the back goes slower and this is a
button and the button will also adjust
like one level up but I want to show you
guys in actual class let me take this
incline back down these are cool I don't
actually click through here the
take you on the road to a 5k this is a
boot camp it's a two-week training
program the 5k is six weeks I'm honestly
really really really like this thing a
lot and this is by the way I'm not
sponsored I bought this
it pre-ordered it and here we are today
talking about it so you can go through
here you can pick different instructors
cuz I feel like after you guys go
through this you're gonna find some of
your favorites let's do an arms and
shoulders do camp my heart rate monitor
is not connected but if I did want to
connect it I would just put this on and
it would connect through bluetooth this
is basically like a huge Android tablet
start might have a watch I hate that I'm
wearing makeup and I'm on a treadmill
right now I just want to say that this
is like my biggest pet peeve is wearing
makeup and working out this thing is
really loud okay
so speed knob for Pocock okay for buffa
we're going and this was actually a live
class in New York so the studio that
she's in is in New York and this was a
live class there's actually people in it
and if you're ever in New York you can
go to the peloton studio and take a
class what does she want me to do oh god
I didn't hear what she said I didn't
hear what you said what did you tell me
to do she said to do something
[Music]
the actual class this one month live
this is one of the video on-demand ones
that I chose as you guys can see over
here I'm not doing so well because I
stopped I am currently in 19th place and
these are all people that have taken
this specific class before all of your
data is all based here you can close
that to hide it I also like so they have
the tracklist here I can see what the
music is that they're playing since I'm
cheating because I'm making your video
I'm gonna get my weights ready because
she's about done to be on the treadmill
I think my favorite part about this is
the fact that you feel like you are
actually in a class with people and you
kind of are interacting but you're not
really you're still alone and you can
choose to do it everywhere I am 23rd but
this is why I really like this a lot
because you're on the treadmill you do
the running but then there's also
strength training as well I should have
picked lighter weights I think you guys
get the point
it's a treadmill but you could also do
things on the floor but I love what
peloton has done with us and I love what
they have done for fitness in general
because it does make it seem like it is
a community thing and I am so excited
about this
I hope put a link in the description if
you guys want to check it out and get
more information these are pretty
expensive but compared to other
treadmills not really sure what these
are called but it's kind of like a
slatted treadmill and this is so much
easier on your knees and when you're
running and a lot of these treadmills
that I price out like that are at the
gyms that I usually go to are like
10,000 to like 12,000 dollars but this
runs you about 4,000 it does have the
integrated computer I mean there's like
literally a computer attached to this
thing but I love it it's been so much
fun to use and I'm looking forward to
doing more classes on this but I would
love to know from you guys what do you
guys do to stay fit do you run do you
hike do you do any sort of martial arts
I would love to know in the comments
below and if you don't do anything join
me this year in trying to get our lives
together because it's been a struggle
this past year but finally I feel like
I'm getting to that point where Fitness
is a priority and I'm super excited for
the future so come join me and I will
see you guys later
but I gotta go take a nap because I'm
tired I already did a big 4 mile hike
this morning and then I did yoga after
and I don't know I think I did too many
activities Martin
I would love some more milk no
absolutely not
[Music]